[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT MAXWELL: And so
welcome Dr. Starkey.
NATALIE STARKEY: Thank you.
SCOTT MAXWELL: I
know that we want
to get to the point of talking
about how these things are
going to kill all of us
and we're all doomed,
but before we do that before we
do that, before we get started
about that, we should talk
a little bit about what
these things are that
are going to kill us all.
So your book, of course,
is a nonfiction book.
But I couldn't help
thinking while reading it
that if it were a novel,
the main characters in it
would be comets and asteroids.
So maybe we should start there.
Talk a little bit about what
comets and asteroids are
and how they are
different from each other.
NATALIE STARKEY: Sure.
So I guess there's a lot
of misunderstanding now
about what the difference is
between comets and asteroids.
So classically we have
this idea that comets
formed in the very cold outer
reaches of the solar system.
So when our Sun
first formed, it was
surrounded by this cloud
of gas and dust and ice.
And way out in the outer reaches
of the solar system, way past
where any of the planets are
today, we form the comets.
And they're
literally just like--
I describe as like a
scoop of this cloud.
You basically just
take this gas and dust
and ice and kind of bind
it together a little bit.
But they're not very
well, like held together.
They're not very
well consolidated.
So they are almost
like a snowball
essentially with a
lot of dust in it.
But why they're so important is
that they're exceptionally old.
So they're as old as the
sun, 4.6 billion years old,
and which means they can tell us
a lot about where we came from,
where everything in our
solar system came from.
SCOTT MAXWELL: They're
sort of primitive objects.
NATALIE STARKEY: Exactly.
Whereas the asteroids
on the other hand,
they're also very old with
saying probably nearly 4.6,
if not--
just about 4.5
billion years old.
And we can think
of those as kind
of the leftover of building
rubble from making the planet.
So they formed in the
inner solar system,
much closer to the sun,
just as the rocky planets
did, like Earth and
Mercury, Venus and Mars.
And it was just those bits
and pieces of planet that
didn't get made into a planet.
They just got left out.
And then they collected in the
asteroid belt, which is now
between Mars and Jupiter.
So the asteroids are really
important because they preserve
this history of planet building,
which is really hard to look
at, because if we
just take earth,
we've had all sorts of evolution
on Earth since it formed.
And we have plate
tectonics, as most people
know, especially living
in LA, you probably
know too well-- there was
an earthquake last night
actually-- that our
plates are moving
and we create earthquakes
and volcanoes.
And this changes the
surface of our planet.
So if we want to go back
to the beginning of Earth,
we want to see what it was made
from and how it started out
and how life got here and
how our water got here,
it's really hard to do.
It's really hard to pick
apart that history's.
So asteroids are really
important in that sense.
They can kind of allow
us to glimpse back
at that time, because
they didn't really
evolve since they formed.
Not a whole lot anyway.
They've sort of preserved
those conditions.
So that's the classic view.
And I think we're going
to come on to, in a bit,
kind of how that view is
maybe not so accurate now.
It's not wholly
wrong, but we've kind
of updated our view
about these objects.
But we remember that that's
the classical distinction.
SCOTT MAXWELL: And
I love that image
of the asteroids as
kind of the leftover
LEGOs from the solar system.
You snapped a whole bunch of
things together into planets
and these are the ones that are
kind of scattered on the floor.
NATALIE STARKEY: Yeah.
That's right.
SCOTT MAXWELL: And
so because these
might come into the
picture as well,
can we talk a little about
what meteors and meteorites
and meteoroids are.
NATALIE STARKEY: Yeah.
So there's a lot of
confusion about that.
So a meteorite is literally
just a piece of rock
from space on another planet.
So on earth, we can go
and collect meteorites
sitting on the ground.
And it could be a
piece of a planet.
It could be a piece of
a comet or an asteroid.
And what happens is that
collisions happen in space
and they happened for millennia.
And little pieces of rocks
will get knocked off planets,
if another-- if an asteroid
collides with them,
and some of this
asteroid might end up
just floating about in space,
but little pieces of it.
So it's a meteoroid in space.
And then when it comes
through the atmosphere,
it becomes a meteor.
So we had the meteor
shower recently.
You can see little
pieces coming through.
Often that's dust.
When we get a big fireball,
these beautiful scenes
that we get, that's a larger
piece of rock coming through.
If that rock makes
it to the surface,
if it doesn't explode
in the atmosphere
and completely disintegrate,
a piece of rock on the surface
is the meteorite.
So the great thing about them
is that we can collect them.
Sometimes and we can
actually see them fall.
If you see a fireball, you can
sometimes trace it and then
find that fresh rock literally
just straight from space
and you can sample it.
Or we get older
falls, where, you
know, these are called finds,
where they fell a while ago.
It could be millions
of years ago.
And we can then go
and sample them.
And it's great because it
means that we can get samples
from space, because
we don't actually
go into space very often,
like we go into space a bit.
And when we do, we often
don't collect samples,
because if we want to go out
and collect samples in space,
it's almost like two missions.
You want to-- this is why
we haven't sampled Mars.
And people find that
quite surprising
when I say we don't have
any samples from Mars.
We've been there a whole lot.
There's loads of
instruments on Mars.
But we haven't brought
back any rocks from there.
SCOTT MAXWELL: It's
not on purpose.
NATALIE STARKEY: Yeah.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Right.
NATALIE STARKEY: So we need
to-- we will be doing it
in the future, but at the
moment, the only rocks
we have from Mars
are meteorites.
So that's the only way
we can sample them.
They're free samples,
which is great,
but we don't know exactly
where they came from.
So if we send a mission
there, we can sample exactly
in a particular basin
that we're interested in
and then we can bring that back.
But that's basically
a second mission
to launch, relaunch
off another planet
or an asteroid or a comet.
It's really complicated.
So that's why we haven't
done it very often obviously.
We have a lot of samples from
the moon, thank goodness.
So that's-- we've done it a
bit, but we need to do it more.
But we have meteorites
in the meantime,
which can really help us out.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So the
asteroids all live--
well, not all live--
but are mainly
collected in the
asteroid belt, which
is this region between the
orbits of Mars and Jupiter.
And the asteroid belt, I
learned from your book,
isn't really all one thing.
There's like an
inner and outer belt
and there's a distinction
between those two regions.
Do you want to talk
about that a little bit.
NATALIE STARKEY: So when
we studied asteroids
and asteroid belt,
we kind of initially
thought they were
all going to be
the same, just these kind
of rocky objects that look
a bit like a failed planets.
And they're all very small.
There are a couple of
large objects there,
but actually when
we look in detail
from the inner
belt, which is going
to be the bit that's closer
to Mars, sure enough,
these things do
look like asteroids.
In fact, some of them are
made completely of metal.
So if you take the core of
Earth, that is made of metal.
We are all probably
aware of that.
But actually, we can sample
a sort of core from a planet
if we sample some
of these asteroids.
And there's a NASA
mission actually going
in the 2020s called
Psyche and it's
going to be going to look
at one of these objects.
So we can sample those.
And they're very
much like we consider
the classical asteroids.
But as we move out
to the outer belt
on that kind of Jupiter
side, what we find
is that they change.
And they actually become
icy, some of these objects.
And they have a lot of
carbonaceous material.
So what I'm saying here is
that we've got organic matter.
Now that's not uncommon.
We have organic matter
in most of the asteroids,
apart from the ones that are
really made of just metal.
This isn't a life.
People get very excited
when we say organic matter.
It's not life.
It's literally just carbon
hydrogen bonding and oxygen
and it's organic matter
that is potentially
the precursor for life.
So it's really exciting
these objects contain
a lot of organic matter, because
we still don't understand
how life got to earth.
We're obviously the only planet
we know of that contains life.
And we don't know
how it got here.
And it's kind of just--
it's ridiculous right.
I always find it quite
funny that we still
don't know how we are here.
And we're like these very
intelligent beings that
can do all sorts of amazing
things, but how we've got here
is a mystery.
So we want to study these
objects to try and understand
if they could have
delivered life.
So these asteroids on the outer
belt, they also contain ice.
So they look very
much like the comets
I described at the beginning.
And actually, this is where
this kind of distinction
between the two objects
breaks down a little bit,
because these actually
might be comets.
When they formed, the
idea is that some of them
really could have formed
in the outer solar system.
And then there was a
huge reorganization
of the solar system after
the large planets formed.
And some of these
comets kind of got
thrown into the
inner solar system
and got trapped in
the asteroid belt.
So we actually find that
they're kind of of comets,
but they are asteroids.
So it's kind of confusing
in that respect.
But the same happened
the other way.
Some of the asteroids
that formed near the sun
got ejected out of
the solar system.
Some of them
probably disappeared
from our solar
system completely.
And others ended up
in one of the homes
of where the comets live now.
So there's probably
almost certainly
some objects in what we call the
Kuiper Belt, where Pluto lives,
which are probably
asteroidal in origin,
but now they're sitting
somewhere very cold.
So there is a build-- this
is where kind of the overlap
starts to happen, because the
solar system's kind of crazy.
SCOTT MAXWELL: I love
that image from your book
of Jupiter sort of
throwing a tantrum
and rampaging around the solar
system and kind of throwing
stuff all over the place and
kind of mixing it all up,
so it's not arranged
in this kind
of neat, tidy little categories
that we thought at first.
NATALIE STARKEY: I
think that's the thing.
We had this beautiful view,
because the solar system
is very hard to understand.
Obviously we need to
visit it to understand
it and we haven't been to--
I mean, we've been
to a lot of it,
but we still don't know
how the planets formed.
And Jupiter is
enormous, like it really
controls our solar system.
And it's gravity, if it
decides to move around,
which it did in the
past, can just really
cause havoc throughout-- it
can just knock planets around
and particularly small
objects like asteroids.
So that is-- and that period
of our solar system history
is very, very crazy.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Yeah.
You talked about swapping the
orbits of Uranus and Neptune.
So Neptune is
further out currently
and Uranus is closer in, but
they were the other way around.
NATALIE STARKEY: Exactly.
This is what we think.
SCOTT MAXWELL: It's really
reconfigured itself a lot.
NATALIE STARKEY: And these
are massive planets, you know?
And they have huge gravity.
So it's kind of a crazy thing.
Obviously it's not
going to happen now,
but what we can do now is look
out to other solar systems,
around other planet planetary
systems, around other stars.
And we can kind of look
at what is happening now.
So I love that this is not my
field, but this is astronomy
and it's absolutely fascinating
that we can look out and see--
we kind of see our
solar system as it
was billions of
years ago, because we
can look at other
stars and see actually
planets forming at
this very time, what
kind of was happening here.
So this is another way
we can try and figure out
what happened 4.6 billion
years ago and afterwards.
So it's fascinating.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Right on.
So in much the same
way that there's
these two regions of
the asteroid belt,
there's kind of two regions of
where the comets live as well.
You talked about the Kuiper
belt, which is the near region,
then there's also
the Oort cloud,
which is the farther region.
You want to talk about the
distinction between those two
regions as well?
NATALIE STARKEY: So, yeah.
SCOTT MAXWELL: How
far away they are?
NATALIE STARKEY:
It's kind of crazy.
So distances in space always--
I think everyone just goes,
oh yeah, it's really far.
It's like, really far to Jupiter
and it's really far to Pluto.
We know we went to Pluto
with the New Horizons mission
recently, and it's still
going through the Kuiper belt.
So a couple of years later, I
think was 2015 it met Pluto.
And it's still going
through the Kuiper Belt
so it is 25 times wider
than the asteroid belt.
And the asteroid belt
was already fairly large.
And it's just-- in terms of
distances, it's not that far.
So it's just past
Neptune, Uranus,
it's kind of just on the
edge of the solar system.
But these objects that
are there, they're icy.
They're dusty.
They're kind of
mostly fairly small.
And we can see most of them.
So we kind of know
roughly what is there.
But they're sort of bound
to our Sun by the gravity.
They're not too far that
they're not kind of bound
to our solar system.
But once you get to the
edge of the Kuiper Belt,
it sort of becomes
no man's land.
We have a region called
the scattered disk,
which is just some random
objects which are probably
mostly cometary and they're kind
of on crazy orbits a little bit
and we don't understand them
a whole lot, but they are--
we can't see all of them--
but they're kind of we
know that they're there.
But then we get to
this theoretical phase
of the solar system,
which is the Oort clouds.
And I was fascinated
to learn when
I did a few years ago that
the Oort Cloud is not proven.
It's theoretical.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Right.
We've never seen it.
It's so far away.
NATALIE STARKEY: And we always
talk about Oort Cloud comets
and, neato, we have what we
call long period comets, which
are these comets that come
into the inner solar system
and orbit the sun
and they have to have
orbits of more than 200 years.
So the way we know the
Oort Cloud is there,
partly because we
have to balance out
the mass of the
solar system somehow.
So we kind of so guess there
had to be something out there.
But then we get these
comets coming in
at really random angles
into the-- so basically
I should probably just
sidestep a little bit.
The solar system,
as most people know,
all the planets are
on the same plane.
And so is the Kuiper Belt. So
we're sort of all going around
the sun nicely.
Pluto is doing something
slightly different.
And then we move out
to the Oort Cloud.
And this is literally a
cloud around the whole sun.
So what happens is, is
when one of these comets
decides to come into
the inner solar system,
they can come in from
all random angles.
They're not going to be
coming along that plane.
So that's how we sort of
know this cloud is there,
because these little visitors
from out to solar system
come in and we can spot them.
But we can't directly see
them if they're there,
because they're
just too far away.
You know, these objects are
tiny and not too far away.
So this is partly why--
so when New Horizons
got to Pluto,
we didn't really
know much about it.
Like we just could not
really see it in any detail.
So I'm really excited
sitting next object
it's going to in
the Kuiper Belt.
And then the Oort
Cloud we just--
you know, we're never going to
get there in anyone's lifetime.
The spaceships will
continue going,
but we are not going to know.
They will have run out of
battery by then anyway.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Right, right.
So doing the math on the
numbers from your book,
I got that light
leaves the sun, it
gets to the near edge of the
Kuiper belt in four hours.
So that's the
Kuiper belt. It gets
to the near edge
of the Oort Cloud
in something like
9 and 1/2 months.
So that's the magnitude
of the difference
that we're talking about.
NATALIE STARKEY: Yup.
And then the Oort
Cloud, it would
take another two years to
cross probably or something
like that, so--
SCOTT MAXWELL: Exactly right.
It's like from one to three
light years of distance.
NATALIE STARKEY: Yes.
So when you're talking
just space craft speeds,
I mean, this is going to take
tens of thousands of years,
I'm guessing.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Right.
It's something like 40,000 years
or something along those lines.
NATALIE STARKEY:
So it's very far.
So I think--
SCOTT MAXWELL: We
don't have batteries
that will last that long.
NATALIE STARKEY: These objects
at barely bound to our sun.
They are actually influenced
often by, in the galaxy,
the passing of other stars.
They can be knocked out of their
orbit by literally other stars
nearby, because they're almost
closer to other solar systems
or stars than our one.
SCOTT MAXWELL:
That was the thing
I was fascinated-- just a
little factoid I was fascinated
by from your book, that the
outer edge of the Oort Cloud,
which is around our
Sun, is actually
closer to the next star
than it is to our Sun.
NATALIE STARKEY: But they are
literally within our solar
system so it's-- yeah, it's kind
of where you define the edge
of the solar system.
And there are
different definitions
for where it is when you enter
interstellar space, which is
the bit in between the stars.
And so yeah, the
Voyager missions,
which set off here in the 1970s,
they are now in interstellar
space, but that just means
they are past the Kuiper Belt
basically.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Right.
As long as we're talking about
like, awesome little facts
from your book,
the asteroid-- this
is a thing that kind
of blew my mind--
the asteroid belt,
all the asteroids
from the asteroid
belt put together,
would have less mass
than Earth's moon.
NATALIE STARKEY: Yeah.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Yeah.
Which is very different
from your picture of it
as you think of the
Millennium Falcon swooping
through the asteroid belt
and the asteroids are all
kind of like huge and
close together, yeah,
but it's really kind of--
NATALIE STARKEY: They're
quite scattered out,
and that's a good
thing, otherwise they
would collide more
often and we would
have more issues in the inner
solar system with potentially
being hit by one.
So actually it's a good thing
that they're nicely far part.
So you can get
through quite easily.
You can find a good route.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Well, that's a
nice little transition for us.
So now that we have a handle
on kind of what all the players
are-- the comets and asteroids
and the solar system,
and the meteors, of course,
once they get here--
let's talk about how they're
going to kill us all.
NATALIE STARKEY: Great.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So
one of the things
that you talked
about in the book
is you kind of point out that
comets and asteroids giveth,
but they also taketh away--
that they might have brought
life to earth, but they also,
you know, wiped
out the dinosaurs
and could do the same to us.
I'm a little hesitant
to ascribe properties
like good and evil to
inanimate objects like that.
Maybe we should talk about
them in helpful or scary.
But how do you think about them?
Do you think that they're
things that should
be revered or feared or--
NATALIE STARKEY: So
I mean, it's probably
no surprise, as somebody
who has researched
these objects for quite a
while, that I revere them.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Fair enough.
NATALIE STARKEY: Because
one of the things about
it is, yes, they do have the
potential to collide with us.
And we think we're safe
for about 100 years.
So probably all
of us, unless you
know how to live a lot
longer than 100 years,
then you're going to be OK.
But the thing is like, are our
descendants going to be OK?
And the more we can learn
about these subjects now,
the better prepared
we are to do something
about one of them hitting us.
So if we don't
understand our enemy,
then we don't know how
to fight it basically.
So I love these objects
because they can tell us
a lot about where we came
from, about our past,
and how everything started
out in the solar system.
But yeah, they do really have
the potential to cause havoc.
A large asteroid could
hit us, past that 100--
I mean, there's a chance one
could hit us within 100 years,
but it's very unlikely.
Past that, we at the
moment don't know.
It's a kind of a
continuously updated list
of potentially hazardous
asteroids and comets, which
astronomers are
studying and they
need to understand better
how they move on their orbit
somewhat-- their next orbit
of the sun is going to do
and if they're going to be
altered by passing Jupiter
in the future or something.
So we need to understand
exactly what they're
doing, how they're
spinning, and then we need
to know what they're made of.
Because if we don't know
what they're made of, well,
some ideas, like you
know "Armageddon,"
if you've seen the
Hollywood movie,
they actually go and
detonate some explosive
inside the asteroid
to blow it up.
Well, it depends what
you're dealing with.
If this asteroid is made of
pure metal, that might not work.
You might not even be able
to drill into the thing
to put some explosive inside it.
But if we're talking
about a comet,
well, maybe if it's
coming towards Earth,
it might just explode on
atmospheric entry anyway.
So it's kind of
like, we need to know
what we're dealing
with if we want
to go and deflect or destroy
one before it gets here.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Right.
And you talk about
this some in the book,
that even blowing
up the asteroid
might not be good,
because now you
have a whole bunch of asteroids
that are going to kill you
instead of one big asteroid--
NATALIE STARKEY: Exactly.
And I think think
one of the things
is like, the more advance
notice we get, the better.
So if we can see that an
object is heading for us
and it's large, say a kilometer
or so, and it's 10 years out,
then we have time
to launch a mission.
This way we need to do a
bit of work in advance,
because of course, it's not
that easy to launch a mission
just straight the next day.
So we need a few years
to figure out how
to launch the mission there.
It would would be
great if we had
one ready to go for any
of these objects, which
are what we're currently working
on and planetary defense.
It's a big topic at
the moment in research.
And governments are
actually interested in this,
which is great, because we
need them to be to support
the research community.
Launch mission, basically the
longer you have the better.
If you want to deflect
something and it's way off,
it's going to be a smaller
nudge to deflect it,
if you just want to
push it out that way
then if it's right
next to earth already,
you're going to have to deflect
it a long way for it to miss.
Ideally, we would
want to deflect them.
We just want to put it
on a different course
so it misses our planet.
And we don't care if
it hits another planet,
but we want to
protect our planet.
We could-- if we're stuck and
we don't have much notice--
we could explode it in some
way, if we can find a way.
Of course, you might need to use
nuclear weapons, which is not
going to be fun, if
you're going to get
the rain of this nuclear weapon
falling down on the planet,
but--
SCOTT MAXWELL: And it's possibly
in violation of treaties,
although that would
probably be forgiven if you
were saving the entire planet.
NATALIE STARKEY: I
think if we-- yeah.
So I think nuclear
weapons aren't
allowed to be used in
spaces like in a bad way,
so I think if we were
saving our planet,
then we'd probably let it go.
And maybe some nuclear
fallout wouldn't
be as bad as just being
hit by an asteroid.
So we might allow it.
But it sounds like
science fiction,
and it is science
fiction, but it's also
now turning into reality.
These are really kind of
what we're thinking of.
There's other crazier
ideas, that we don't
have to explode these things.
There's other ideas
that we can spray
paint one side of this object.
So generally these
objects are very dark.
And as they go by the sun,
they're obviously heated up.
Now if you can change
one side of the asteroid,
if you could spray
painted white or metallic,
it's going to heat
up differently
as it goes near to
the sun and it all
starts spinning differently.
And if it spins
differently, it'll
change its orbit gradually.
So these are very
gentle techniques.
It sounds a bit mad trying
to spray paint in space,
but this is literally one of the
things we can do, or cover it
with something to
kind of change how
it reacts to the sun's heat.
SCOTT MAXWELL: You know, I never
saw the movie "Armageddon,"
but I gather what it's about.
NATALIE STARKEY:
You haven't seen it?
Wow.
SCOTT MAXWELL: I
haven't seen it.
I gather what it's about is they
sent basically miners to space.
NATALIE STARKEY: They sent
Ben Affleck and Bruce Willis
up there because they
were oil miners, yeah,
they were drillers.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So
it never occurred--
like I kind of get that-- but it
never occurred to me that maybe
what you want to send is
taggers that could spray paint--
NATALIE STARKEY:
That's a good idea--
SCOTT MAXWELL: Right?
Like maybe they would do it.
They would put a nice mural on
the side that would look pretty
as it passed us by safely.
We're gonna work on that.
That's your next book.
NATALIE STARKEY: I
think I should do that.
I could do the novel.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Yeah.
The novelization of the--
NATALIE STARKEY: But
yeah, I mean, of course,
we're not actually
going to send people up.
In reality, what's going to
happen is that we use robots.
And in space, of
course, all the time
we use robots, just because
they're more expendable.
We don't really care if
we killed the robots.
We care because they cost a lot
and a lot of people's careers
go into making them--
SCOTT MAXWELL: Some of us
really fall in love with them.
NATALIE STARKEY: Don't we all?
But it's not human.
So there's big issues of
sending humans into space.
If we're going to send them
to land on an asteroid,
well asteroids don't have
an awful lot of gravity,
because they're small objects.
So they're going to
have to be tethered on.
I can't remember what
they did in "Armageddon."
I think they were just
roaming about freely.
They would probably have floated
off into space, you know.
So it's not easy to send
humans to these objects.
I'm sure it will happen in the
future, way into the future.
But for now, it will be robots,
which again, is not easy,
because as you
know, you're trying
to run a robot from Earth
and millions of miles away,
it has it's issues.
Communication times are tricky
because it takes a long time
to communicate.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Right.
Can't joystick it.
NATALIE STARKEY:
And things go wrong.
Like I ran a lab
instrument for many years
and I could be in
there tinkering with it
and if something went wrong,
I could change things.
But if that instrument is
way off on an asteroid,
there's nothing you can do.
If it breaks, there's not
really an awful lot you can do.
So yeah, there's lots of issues.
SCOTT MAXWELL: But
we have actually
sent space missions
to these objects,
to comets and asteroids before.
And I would say it was pretty
evident from reading your book
that you're a big fan of
both the Stardust and Rosetta
missions.
NATALIE STARKEY: I am.
Yeah.
They got a chapter--
SCOTT MAXWELL: And speaking
of landing something
on one of those objects,
Rosetta actually did that.
Tell us a little bit
about those missions
and what they accomplished.
NATALIE STARKEY: I mean,
the NASA Stardust mission
was like-- it had happened.
It had brought it samples back,
as I was starting my career
in this area of science.
So the NASA Stardust was
really groundbreaking.
It was actually quite
a cheap mission,
and it flew to comet belt II.
And it wanted to
bring a sample back.
But it didn't have enough
money to land on this object
and come back from it.
So they flew through
the tail of the comet.
So I've mentioned that comets
have a lot of ice and dust
in them.
And as they go by the sun,
this material gets heated up.
So sure enough, the ice
streams of the comet
and takes dust with it.
And that's what
produces the tail, when
you get in the famous
comets that you
see all the beautiful images
of, that tail of material
is literally the gas and dust
coming off of that comet.
And so what they
did was just flew
through the tail of this
comet and literally just got
impacting particles
on this collector.
And that was their
comet samples.
And they closed up
their little collector
and jettisoned it back to Earth.
And the rest the
space car carried on.
And we have those
samples back in 2006.
And they were our first
real samples of a comet,
because it's hard to know
if we've got any meteorites
or comets, because
as I said earlier,
they probably explode as
they enter the atmosphere.
So it's hard to know we've
definitely got one on earth.
So this was a real
groundbreaking mission.
And then it also
really turned the books
on how we thought comets formed.
And what it showed us was that
actually, we know it's a comet.
It behaves like a comet.
We know its orbit, that it
comes from the Kuiper Belt.
And then what we find
is that actually it
doesn't look like a comet.
When we look at the rocks within
it, they look like an asteroid.
So it doesn't sound
very exciting,
but you're like,
hold on a minute,
this thing formed way out
in the outer solar system,
yet it's got components
within it that look exactly
like the planets,
that look exactly
like the building blocks
of the planets that
form very close to the sun.
So how do we get
ice and hot material
contained within one object?
So this was why
everything got blown apart
at this stage and
the scientists--
you know, and they're
still working on it.
We're still trying
to understand how
we get hot material from
the inner solar system
out to the comet forming region
to form a comet that then is
covered in ice and dust all
the normal stuff that we expect
it to contain.
And there's lots of
different theories,
but that is still
an ongoing area
that we need to understand.
So we know that the
story is not as simple
as it could, as we
would like it to be,
as the textbooks
would have us believe.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Before
we move on, to Rosetta,
Stardust also brought
us back-- in addition
to bringing us back the first
sample from a comet, brought us
back samples of
interstellar particles.
NATALIE STARKEY: It did, yeah.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Turn the detector
around, did it the other way,
and collected a few
of those as well.
NATALIE STARKEY: Yeah.
Basically we have particles
from interstellar space,
which is the space around all
the stars in the solar system.
And these particles are
traveling exceptionally fast.
And we haven't really been
able to sample them before.
So this kind of-- it was called
like a tennis racquet style
collector.
It kind of just came up
out of the spacecraft.
One side collected
comet particles
and then the back side collected
interstellar particles.
And they're tiny.
They're like so
tiny that we can't--
the comet particles are small.
I'm saying like
probably a maximum
of like the width
of a human hair
would be the largest particles
we collected, if that.
The interstellar particles are
10 times smaller than that.
So they're very hard
to see on the collector
and they're very
hard to analyze.
But there was a whole instrument
built somewhere in LA,
or somewhere in California.
I can't remember which
university it's at.
But they basically
made a whole instrument
to measure these particles,
because we can sample then
our galaxy, because
we have no other way.
We haven't been able to
go out to our galaxy,
but these particles come to us.
So we can actually
start to understand
what our galaxy looks
like, what it's made of,
which is fascinating.
So yeah, it just did
so much that mission.
It was fascinating.
SCOTT MAXWELL: There were
there were some other really
interesting things in there.
You go into it a lot of
detail about exactly how they
were able to get some of
those samples out and so on.
We might want to
come back to that.
But I did want to also give you
a chance to talk about Rosetta
as well, because
it's fascinating.
Such a great mission.
NATALIE STARKEY: So I was
just really well-placed.
See, I'm really
lucky to be where
I was working when the
Rosetta mission was ongoing.
Now I have to say, I wasn't
in it from the beginning,
because it took 20 years
to plan this mission.
In fact, I think when
it was originally
being planned, I was
probably still in school,
like primary kind of
school, very early.
And then it took a long
time to build the mission
and then it took 10 years for
it to actually-- from launch--
to get to its comet.
So it had this massive
journey in the solar system
to catch up with this comet.
So this comet called 67P
Churyumov-Gerasimenko.
SCOTT MAXWELL: I can't do that.
I just-- like everybody else,
I just say Cherry Jerry.
NATALIE STARKEY: Oh yeah.
You can say CG or 67P.
It's a long name.
But it was traveling into
the inner solar system.
And the idea was
that they launch
and had to do some decent
gravitational slingshots
of different planets
to catch up with it,
get enough speed, because
you can't just launch
and go directly into a comet.
That's literally
not how it works.
So we have to just
catch up with it.
So got onto an orbit eventually
to catch up with the comet.
Came up on it from behind
and then entered into orbit
around this thing.
Now we've never
done this before.
So you know, Stardust just
flew through the tail.
But Rosetta was just amazing.
It got to the comet and it
basically had to do a power--
it couldn't get
into orbit around it
because this object is small.
It wasn't a real orbit--
SCOTT MAXWELL: So there's
not enough gravity--
NATALIE STARKEY: Powered
flight around it.
So these people
doing engineering
and all this science
for this mission,
I just am amazed by
how they did this.
But they didn't even know
what this object looked like.
Before we got there,
we had no idea
of its shape or its exact size.
We were expecting it
to be sort of round,
because we always kind
of envisage these objects
to be sort of round.
And we got there and it turned
out to be like a rubber ducky,
and the thing is, it
caught everyone's attention
in the media quite a
lot, because it literally
looks like a rubber duck.
It's got this head
and this body.
And I can't imagine
how you figure out
how to fly around that thing
without bumping into it
or whatever.
But we started to get
images back from this comet
and then mapped 100% of
the surface of the comet,
because they had to pick
somewhere to put a Lander down.
Again, they built this
Lander 20 years previous
and they didn't know what they
were going to be landing on.
Do you call it candyfloss here?
The stuff you eat at the fair.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Cotton candy.
Thank you.
NATALIE STARKEY: Cotton Candy.
So we call it candyfloss.
So one of the scientists
likened it to like they
didn't know if they were going
to be landing on candyfloss
or cotton candy or cement.
They had no idea if it's
concrete hard or very soft
and they were going to sink in.
So they had to build a lander--
SCOTT MAXWELL: You just have
to build a spacecraft that's
going to land on something
that you don't know what it--
NATALIE STARKEY: You
have no idea what it is.
It's easy.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Exactly.
NATALIE STARKEY: So you know,
they let the little lander go.
And the Lander is
called a [? fili. ?]
And it just dropped
to the comet.
But again, remember,
there's not much gravity.
So the comet is not
attracting that thing to it.
The comet is still
rotating in space.
So they have chosen a landing
spot and they're like, yeah,
we're going to
land exactly here.
And sure enough,
it did initially
land exactly where
they wanted it
to go on this object
that's like three by five
kilometers in size.
So it's no big.
And it all hurtling towards
the sun at the same time.
Unfortunately, some
stuff went wrong.
One of the harpoons
that was meant
to fire when they landed
in order to kind of hold
onto the surface
and tether it there,
they already knew when they were
going through their procedures
before they were
going to release
fly that it wasn't working.
So they already thought,
what can we do about this?
There's nothing we can.
We have to just go for it now.
We have to test it.
So they did their job right.
They got exactly
where they wanted to.
But the little lander bounced.
And it bounced about
kilometer up into the air.
Now the issue is that it could
have just completely left
the comet because it
wasn't going to go back.
It didn't bounce quite
high enough that it left.
So it went back down again.
And it took a few hours.
And then it landed again
and had another bounce.
So it's kind of hilarious.
It did the kind of
three landings in space
and they were only
planning to do one.
Unfortunately where it ended
up was not the optimal position
for the solar panels.
So it was kind of
under a slight cliff,
but we then learned that
comets have cliffs on them
and overhanging sections.
It's kind of crazy.
But it did run.
It ran its primary
science sequence
when it got initially
to the comet.
So we actually ended up
sampling some of the comet gases
and some of the dust that was
from the initial landing site.
And did some further
science later on.
So we still learn an
awful lot-- so it kind of
seems like a failure, but
it wasn't a failure at all.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Not at all.
NATALIE STARKEY: It got a
huge amount of science done.
And we had-- where I was working
at Open University in the UK,
we had one of the
instruments on the lander.
So we had a mass
spectrometer that
could measure some
of the components
from the gases in there.
So we got to learn
what was on the comet.
SCOTT MAXWELL: And
to your surprise,
you got samples from
like, three places.
I used to work with this guy,
Ray Arvidsson, great guy, who
would say all the time,
there's no bad data.
And so just because you
didn't get the exact data
that you planned to
get doesn't mean you
didn't get some great stuff.
You got the stuff from--
because it was bouncing,
you got it from like--
NATALIE STARKEY: We actually
got multiple locations.
And then we still
have the orbiter
that was still orbiting
around or flying
around the comet at the
time and doing its own work.
It was measured lots
of other experiments
and doing lots of other work
and measuring dust coming off it
and collecting that and looking
at the plasma environment, how
the comet reacts
to the sun, which
is very important, because
we don't really know
how comets react to the sun.
We know that they get heated
up and it all comes off.
But we found out that
actually every time
this comet, 67P,
went by the sun,
it loses about a meter of
material off its surface.
So it gets smaller and smaller
because those volatile ices
and everything get heated
up and blown off the comet--
SCOTT MAXWELL: They all
have to go somewhere.
NATALIE STARKEY: That dust
that is sitting above it, it's
that kind of dehydrated layer
on top, and it all comes off.
So you lose a huge
amount of material.
So it's a very
active environment.
A comet is constantly changing.
You go, oh yeah, they're
these old objects
and they preserve the very old
history of our solar system,
but actually if they
come by the sun,
they're changing all the time.
And we see they have seasons.
We notice that the comet
had different seasons on it
depending on where
you were on the comet
and where it was in
relation to the sun.
So and that moves
material around the comet.
We see movement of, you
know, like active processes,
like you would see on a planet.
It's crazy.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Yeah.
That's amazing I hadn't
heard that before.
That's really cool.
So long as we're talking
about these space missions,
I just want to give
a quick shout out
to the Dawn mission, which
after 11 years of exploring
the asteroids Vesta and Ceres is
running out of maneuvering fuel
kind of middle of next month.
And so it's going to
say goodbye to us.
But just a little
shout out to Dawn
for a long and
honorable mission,
increasing our understanding
of the very objects
that we're talking about here.
So you were talking about--
we talked about this earlier,
that there isn't necessarily
a sharp distinction between
these asteroids and comets.
And so now that we've
had these missions
to kind of look at
asteroids close up
and look at comets
close up, we're
kind of learning more
about how like there
isn't asteroids and comets.
There's more like kind of
attractors in the space
where there's things
that we would confidently
call asteroids and things we
would confidently call comets,
but also a lot of things
kind of in between.
So what have we learned
from these missions
that kind of helps us understand
that continuum a little better?
So
NATALIE STARKEY: We think--
we've learned that-- for me,
I think what I've learned
is it almost doesn't matter.
So we have objects that sit at
either end of this continuum.
But if we want to
study our solar system,
it really doesn't matter
which ones we study too much.
And the ones in the middle are
probably the most fascinating
because they contain
the primitive material.
So the ones that
contain a lot of carbon
and a lot of organic matter.
The ice is important,
but actually
understanding the dust that
came from the beginning
of the solar system is great
and the organic matter.
And so the next
two missions that
are going to study these objects
are both going to asteroids.
So we've got a Osiris Rex,
which is a NASA mission.
And there's a Japanese
mission called Hayabusa II.
They did Hayabusa I already
and that collected some sample
and brought that back.
And so we've had-- it didn't
go completely successfully,
so they're taking
another try and going
to do it perfectly this time.
But these two missions have
arrived at the asteroids.
And they're both basically
primitive asteroids.
So they're almost--
they're not cometary-like.
They're still asteroids.
But they have a lot of
primitive material in.
So we can try and understand
these kind of beginnings
of the solar system.
So they're both going to
be bringing samples back.
I've forgotten right now what
dates we're talking about,
but it's kind of within
five years, I think,
or something like that,
will be returning materials.
So they've started their
mapping phase of these objects
and they're going
to be looking where
they're going to put their
landers down and sampling.
But it's proper
science fiction stuff.
I love it.
It's just fascinating
they can do this.
SCOTT MAXWELL: We are going
to the solar system and like,
going to visit comets
and asteroids where
they live and like, bringing
stuff back from there.
Yeah, that's really
amazing stuff.
So we talked a little about how
they're going to kill us all.
And what we would do about it.
So we talked about kind of
like spray painting asteroids
and things like that.
One of the techniques I
had not heard about before,
before reading your
book, was gravity tugs,
which is another interesting
way of diverting asteroids
or comets off their path.
And it is nice because it works
with unconsolidated things
as well.
Want to explain how
a gravity tug works?
NATALIE STARKEY: So
some of these objects,
even the asteroids, like I said
the comets were not very well
consolidated, not very
well held together,
because this is a scoop
of cloud kind of thing.
And some of the asteroids
on the other hand, also
are unconsolidated.
They might be made
of rocky material.
But imagine just getting
like a load of big pebbles
and just kind of
sticking them together.
And they're sort of
held there because this
is a bit of gravity and there's
nothing really acting on them
in space that would mean that
they wouldn't just all fall
apart.
So they're sort of
loosely bound together.
These objects are particularly
dangerous because they're
hard to move.
If you want to hit
them with something,
they're probably just
going to break up.
So we have to be very
gentle with them.
If we know one of these
objects is heading towards us,
it's hard to know how they're
going to behave when they
come through the atmosphere.
So the gravity tractor
thing is almost just
taking a spacecraft up and
using thrusters on one side
to sort of gently nudge--
and basically it's the
attraction between that rubble
pile and that spacecraft,
which isn't very much,
but if you've got
enough advance warning,
you start doing that
little playing game
and like, nudging it back
and forth early enough,
then it will change its orbit.
So essentially you kind of
want to nudge it very gently.
And it's just that
gravitational attraction
between the two
objects, which obviously
happens even if they're small,
there is still something there.
So that would be very useful
if it were a rubble pile
style asteroid.
I could work with
other ones, but I
think that's probably the
safest way to me one of those--
maybe.
SCOTT MAXWELL: But you know,
more research needed, right?
NATALIE STARKEY: Yeah.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Yeah.
And that's something
we haven't done before.
We actually have fired
a bullet basically,
Deep Space One fired a bullet
into the side of a comet,
but we haven't tried these
other techniques at all.
NATALIE STARKEY: So yeah--
SCOTT MAXWELL: It's all kind
of theoretical at this point.
NATALIE STARKEY: There's a
mission called Deep Impact--
Deep
SCOTT MAXWELL: Impact.
Excuse me.
NATALIE STARKEY: Don't confused
it with the movie "Deep
Impact," and that was
confused in my book,
because my editor was like,
oh, you've got a mission
called Deep Impact.
There's also a Hollywood
movie called Deep Impact.
And I was like, yeah,
that's complicated.
So I think I ended up
taking out all references--
SCOTT MAXWELL: Now
they need to do
a NASA mission
called Armageddon.
NATALIE STARKEY: Yes, that would
be good, just to confuse it.
So yeah, this mission
actually basically pushed
a boulder, fired a boulder into
the side of this comet to see--
well, basically to see what
would happen, because it's fun,
but also to excavate
a hole so that we
could see inside the comet.
It was kind of already
a little bit wrong,
because they created so
much dust from this impact
that the spacecraft
couldn't then see anything.
There was just so
much dust everywhere.
But luckily actually
the Stardust mission,
when it carried on, when
it had got it samples
and sent those back, the
Stardust next mission
had carried on.
And it managed to
image that hole
in that crater that was created.
So we got to see
processes happening.
And again, they saw
changes happening over time
in that crater they created.
So you see, they've got this
kind of active comet thing
again, which is really cool.
So yes, it's kind of one
space mission did it.
And then we came back
and had another look.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Right.
So we're at just
about 40 minutes here.
And probably about time to start
kind of mixing in some audience
questions.
While we're kind of
finding the first victim
and giving them the
mic, one of the major--
another major topic in your
book was about mining asteroids
and comets.
So they actually
contain material that
would be useful to us on earth.
It's not just organics, but
also nickel and platinum
and things like that.
You want to talk a little
bit about mining techniques
and what the state
of the art there is?
NATALIE STARKEY: Sure.
So of course, again it
sounds like science fiction.
It's like, do we really
need to mine in space?
But you know, those
companies, a lot of them--
a lot of stuff going on in
California where we want--
there's actually
companies investing
in this trying to think, can
we go and mine these objects?
We could mine the moon.
There's lots of materials on
the moon that would be useful.
But equally, it might be
easier to mine asteroids.
They can be easier to get to
and they don't have gravity,
so they're easy
to get back from,
if we want to launch
a mission back.
And they contain a lot
of precious metals,
so we all love our
smartphones and everything,
computers-- obviously
we're in Google.
So we like all these materials
that require precious metals.
And if we're going to continue
creating new technologies
in the future, we
need to know we've
got a reliable source of things
like palladium, platinum,
all these things that
are used in technology.
We won't be able to
develop new technologies
if we don't know we've got a
continued source of this stuff.
And on earth, things
like platinum,
well, it's expensive because
there's not much of it.
We find it very hard to mine.
It's very dispersed throughout
the crust of the earth
and it's expensive
to mine and often
not very good to the
environment to get out.
If we go to asteroid,
well, there's tons of it.
Actually there's
probably more platinum
in some single asteroids
than we've ever mined
on the whole of the planet.
So we run into
economical issues.
If we were to mine it and
bring it back to Earth,
well, we'd crush the market.
And obviously then
it will probably
be not worth having done
the whole mining thing.
Maybe we store it like
we do with diamonds
and we release it gradually
and control the market.
Anyway, I'm not an economist.
But there are issues
to doing that.
It may cost trillions
of dollars--
literally trillions of
dollars to actually launch
these missions and go
and mine these objects.
But the chances you
could actually--
they could be worth
way more than that.
So there is-- I guess if
you have a lot of money
and you think it will be
fun to go mine asteroids,
there is the potential you
could make a lot of money.
Of course, we need reusable
rockets, because it's just
too expensive otherwise.
We need to-- so that
obviously a lot of companies
are working on that
right now, being
able to cheapen getting
stuff into space,
because it's just
massively expensive.
But if we can find
ways around this--
and I think progress is
definitely being made
at the moment--
we can get to space
cheaply and we can
start to mine these objects.
But we don't have to bring
all that stuff back to Earth.
It could be useful in space.
And we want to go to Mars.
We want to venture out
further into our solar system.
But we need--
first of all, fuel.
It's very expensive to
bring fuel from earth.
If we want to go out into
the solar system, fine.
We have enough fuel
for a little while.
But then if we want to land
somewhere and go and visit
somewhere else, we need fuel.
And if we launch it from earth,
it's just very, very expensive.
The more fuel you
take, the more fuel you
need to take that fuel.
And there's an
exponential relationship
and it just gets crazy.
So if we can find
the fuel in space,
then sure enough we have water.
If we can split water
into hydrogen, oxygen,
we can create rocket
fuel in space.
So again, it sounds
like science fiction,
but we can then also use these
objects to make materials
in space.
3D print what we
require, instead
of taking all our tools from
Earth, which we currently do.
If we go to the
International Space Station,
we have to take
everything with us.
And we have to launch
missions just to resupply it.
Well, we wouldn't
need to do that.
We could just actually
go and 3D print.
So they're actually testing a
3D printer on the International
Space Station, and it
sounds crazy, but yeah.
That is something we could do.
We just mine the asteroid,
get the materials we need,
and make the tools we
require into space.
So yeah, it's happening.
It seems like-- I think the
first steps in asteroid mining
are probably going to happen
within the next few decades.
They're very tentative steps, of
like getting there, prospecting
basically, seeing what
these objects contain,
and then figuring out
what kind of missions
we require to maybe tug them
into an orbit where they're
sort of safe and they're
going to sit quite happily
so that we can then
launch a mission
to mine them in some way.
Whether we need humans,
it's unknown at the moment.
This is why people talk about
needing a moon base for lunar
base for humans to live, and
that they could then mine
from the moon kind of thing.
So it's a lot of
unknowns at the moment,
but there's definitely
progress being made.
And like the US has created
laws now about mining in space
and who owns the
materials they've mined.
So any US citizen
theoretically, if they
mine something in space,
they can own that stuff,
which is kind of crazy.
And I don't know what
the rest the world
thinks about this at the moment.
I think Luxembourg are
following very similar laws.
I don't know if they've
passed them yet.
But again, Luxembourg is tiny.
I don't know if you've
been, but there's not
many people that live there.
So I'm not sure how many
people are Luxembourg citizens.
But yeah, is that fair?
I kind of think, well,
I'm not a US citizen.
I want to go and mine space.
But I wouldn't be
allowed at the moment
to own the space that I mine.
So yeah, a lot of issues,
and a lot of global issues,
I think, that we need--
SCOTT MAXWELL: But it seems
like they're worth working out
because there's so much--
potentially so
much wealth there.
And it it's not just wealth
in terms of making you rich,
but wealth in terms
of, as you said,
things like resources
to make smart phones
and stuff like that.
NATALIE STARKEY: Exactly.
SCOTT MAXWELL: I never really
thought about this before,
but asteroids like have all
these resources that we need
and a whole lot of fuel that
we can use to help further
explore the solar system.
Asteroids are basically
the convenience stores
of outer space.
NATALIE STARKEY: Yeah, I kind of
said they're the gas stations.
You just kind of pop there
and get what you need
and then carry on.
Of course, it's not
as simple, but yeah, ,
I kind of like that idea, that
it might happen in the future.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So I think we
have an audience question.
Is it ready to go?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was going to ask about
asteroid mining, so--
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT MAXWELL: Good.
I've ruined your question.
I'm sorry, Bryant.
AUDIENCE: I actually
have a question.
Have you ever seen
the movie Melancholia?
NATALIE STARKEY: No.
AUDIENCE: You ever heard of it?
AUDIENCE: Check it out.
Basically the
premise of that movie
is that a large planet sized
body is heading towards Earth
about the size of Jupiter.
It's huge.
NATALIE STARKEY:
Oh, my goodness.
AUDIENCE: It's huge,
like just ginormous.
The whole thing is that the
scientific community sees it
well in advance, like
several years in advance.
NATALIE STARKEY: I mean,
you would see that coming.
AUDIENCE: So they're planning
it and they're releasing
all this information--
I don't want to give away
too much of the movie,
but the premise is
that it basically
slingshots around the Earth.
And they think
it's going to pass,
but the slight tug of
gravity from the Earth
is just enough where
it reaches its apex
that it turns around and
comes straight back after it.
So my question would
be like, you're
kind of doing a theoretical
science around how
we would deflect
or move something
that is smaller than earth.
NATALIE STARKEY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
science or theoretical physics
and science going on about
how we would move something
that could be much, much--
NATALIE STARKEY: No.
AUDIENCE: Larger
than the planet.
NATALIE STARKEY: I think there's
almost 0% chance of anything
larger than the
Earth hitting Earth,
because the solar system
has settled down now.
So like I mean 4.5
billion years ago,
Earth was hit by a
Mars-sized body, we think.
And that's what actually
formed the moon.
So it collided with the Earth.
We're not sure of
the details of that,
whether it was a direct impact
or a kind of a side shot,
but it probably, almost
certainly vaporized the Earth.
And then from that, we formed
our Earth again, but also
our moon.
So that's the kind of thing
that would happen here.
It would just be completely
obliterated if anything larger
than Mars were to hit us.
But at this stage, the
solar system is settled
and, I mean, I think it just
couldn't happen, but I mean,
you never know.
SCOTT MAXWELL: I'm sure it makes
for a good movie all the same.
Have you seen this
mic by the way?
This is really cool.
You can just toss it around.
NATALIE STARKEY:
I did wonder what
it was when it was sat up here.
AUDIENCE: So I was
fascinated to hear
about the inner and
outer asteroid belt.
And it sounds like they're
materially different.
I mean, the outer one
has a bit more ice,
which maybe you'd expect.
It's farther from the sun.
But other than that, are
these different populations?
NATALIE STARKEY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so
what segregates them?
NATALIE STARKEY: So it's just
probably more based on density.
So the inner objects
are denser and formed
under hotter conditions so
they're more consolidated.
They're rocky.
They're metal-y The ones on
the outer edge probably--
they probably formed
when the comets formed
and were knocked into there.
So they are a lot--
less dense, so they probably
have a lot of pore space.
So actually when we got
to the Rosetta comet,
M67P we were able to
measure its density, which
is really cool, because
although it's made of rock
and it's made of
ice, it actually
has a really low
density, because it's
got lots of holes in it.
So they're not big holes,
not like gaping big holes
in the side of
it, like cavities.
But it's very porous,
very fine scale--
but very porous, like it's
got a lot of gaps in it.
So it's just not very
well pushed together,
whereas the objects on
the inner asteroid belt
are very kind of--
probably no pore
space whatsoever.
So that basically controls it.
So these, as you
move on out, you've
just probably got a
transition gradually
from the inner to outer.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: In college.
I did something where we had
designed these transmitters
to put on near-earth objects.
There was a lot of concern
that the smaller objects that
were harder to detect could
be the thing that does us in,
instead of the larger objects
that are easier to detect.
NATALIE STARKEY: Yep.
AUDIENCE: And it was just--
it was a design class.
We didn't actually deploy it.
But is there any movement
in trying to do anything
to look at near-earth objects?
NATALIE STARKEY: So yeah.
We are currently
tracking basically all
the near-earth objects
that we can possibly see.
The ones that are caught
sort of in normal orbits.
They say those ones
because there couldn't
be some random objects
that are, at the moment,
far out that are going to
become near-earth objects.
But we don't know
they're coming yet,
because they're very small.
So those are kind of the
unknown unknowns, I guess.
But the ones that
we can see and we
are tracing the
orbits of all the
time-- so we're
constantly updating
where we think
they're going and how
they're spinning, because it's
very important to understand
how they heated up.
I said earlier about
deflecting them.
If you paint one side
a different color,
it will spin differently.
Well, there's two effects
that happen in space.
[? York ?] and Yarkovsky effect.
And that determines
how these things spin
and how it affects
their orbit basically
as they're heated up by the sun.
So we sort of know most of
them aren't going to hit us,
but we need to just define
those two phenomena very clearly
and then we can know exactly
where they're going to go.
So some of these objects are
on sort of a hazardous list,
but we just need
to better define
exactly where they're
going and then
they can be removed
from that list.
But yeah, when we're talking
about the size of these things,
it's funny, because
even if it was just
a couple of hundred
meters across,
it could still cause
a lot of damage,
depending on it was made of.
If it's a pure piece of
metal, yeah, sure enough.
It's going to probably
get through the atmosphere
quite easily.
And wherever that hits, it might
not cause global devastation
like we saw with the
dinosaurs being killed off,
but it could cause
quite a lot of issues.
And we've had impacts
in the past which
haven't been
massive, but they can
create things like nuclear
winters essentially.
You can have years--
like when you get a massive
volcanic eruption, like it's
the same kind of thing.
You can change the
climate of the planet
for a considerable time.
And I would suggest
that humans are fairly
kind of a vulnerable species.
We want clean water.
We require movement around
the planet quite a lot.
And I think if anything
like that happened,
we could be quite
vulnerable species.
So even if it was
a smallish impact,
it could just cause
quite a lot of issues.
But obviously the
larger impacts,
if we're talking kilometer
sized bodies, a little larger,
they're going to be
a bigger problem.
So understanding those
kind of small ones
that are still quite large
is a really important area.
Kind of 400 meters across and
so they're pretty dangerous
and they're hard to see.
So we need to understand those,
especially if they're dark.
If they're proper like dark,
carbonaceous asteroids,
they're very hard
to see, because they
don't give off much light.
So that's what
astronomers rely on,
these things giving off light.
That's why comets
are easier to see.
They shine.
Whereas asteroids
can be a bit sneaky.
So we have to be careful.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the interstellar dust
that was collected.
It might be outside the
scope of this conversation,
but I was wondering if it gives
us any kind of understanding
of the original Big Bang
and maybe supporting
the theory of the
Big Bang, or is it
really more like stuff
that's 4.6 million years old
and is very localized dust?
NATALIE STARKEY: So
I'm going to have say,
I don't know to that,
actually, because I've not
kept up with that
interstellar stuff very well.
But I know that it's
basically allowing us
to look into our local galaxy.
And I don't exactly know
when that dust was formed.
But what they've been
able to do is actually
measure the isotopes of the
elements of that material,
and that allows us
to understand a lot
about our local
environment, like what
our solar system formed from.
And obviously we expect
that different galaxies
are going to be different
compositions, because they
formed at different times maybe.
I mean, we still don't
really understand all of that
because we haven't been
able to sample it or look
at it very clearly because
these things are so far away.
So it's kind of understanding
a little bit further back
in our history what is in there.
But yeah, I'd have
to say I'm not sure.
AUDIENCE: So recently
there was big news
about this asteroid from
outside the solar system that
blitzed through.
NATALIE STARKEY: I'm so
glad you mentioned this.
We hadn't mentioned it yet.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Is that something that was
a 1 in 100 year event or was
that a question of our
sensors are getting better
and we can expect to see
more of them the more--
NATALIE STARKEY: Exactly.
The latter.
So we think-- so I'll just
backtrack a little bit.
So this object came
through our solar system.
We actually think now
it was probably a comet,
but we're not 100% sure.
We weren't able to measure it
very well because we didn't
know it was coming, but so
it wasn't on the normal orbit
that all the other comets and
asteroids and planets are on.
It just literally came zipping
through our solar system.
It was so fast
that it didn't even
get caught into the
gravity of our sun.
It just zipped by.
And it came from some
other star system.
We have idea where.
And it's probably been some like
interstellar travel forever.
Who knows when it formed?
It came from very far away.
So it's been going for at
least billions of years.
And it just zipped through.
So we don't know a lot about it.
We just know that it's--
I think called Mu--
is it called Mu-ama?
Like I think it's Hawaiian for--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I didn't
know how to pronounce it.
NATALIE STARKEY:
Amua-mua, I think.
And I think that's Hawaiian for
something like distant traveler
or something like this.
I probably pronounced it wrong.
I don't know Hawaiian.
But basically if we knew
one of these was coming,
we could launch
a mission, again,
to go and sample it, because
this would be fascinating.
We'd learn about
that star system
that it came from, which could
be completely different to what
we're seeing here.
Probably would be.
It could be the same.
Who knows?
But we know it came
from somewhere else.
And we just haven't seen
one of these before.
I think probably other
objects like that
have gone through
the solar system,
but we haven't spotted them.
They go very fast.
I think it was just chance
that it was seen as well.
But it is fascinating.
And I would love to have
some sample of that comet.
It would be so cool to analyze.
But yeah, I'm hoping--
you know, in the future
as we get better at seeing
these things coming-- again,
it wasn't very big.
It was also really
weirdly shaped.
It was like a cigar shape,
really long and kind of
like-- you know, maybe
it's some alien spaceship.
Who knows?
SCOTT MAXWELL: So
basically you're
saying we're being visited
by cigars and rubber ducks?
NATALIE STARKEY: Yeah.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Groucho
Marx would be so happy.
So we just have a
couple of minutes left
and I wanted to ask you
if European Space Agency
or NASA or somebody
came to you and said,
hey, we'd like you to be the
principal investigator that
is the top science person for
the next space mission that's
going to go and maybe
explore one of these objects,
what would you want it to be?
What would you do
with that mission?
NATALIE STARKEY: Well, I
wouldn't be able to choose.
At the moment, we've got
these missions Osiris Rex--
SCOTT MAXWELL: Well, they're
not giving you two missions.
Just one.
NATALIE STARKEY: So I would want
to go and explore the Kuiper
Belt better, get samples of it.
I'd want to explore
more of the comets.
But equally, some of the really
exciting scientific things
happening right now are
Enceladus and Europa.
Now this isn't
comets and asteroids,
but this is potentially finding
life in our solar system.
These are moons of
Jupiter and Saturn
and they have liquid oceans
beneath their icy crust.
And there's a really
high potential
that they could have life--
probably not intelligent life,
but there could be life there.
And for me at the moment,
I'm just fascinated by that.
And I-- we are going to one.
We're going to Europa.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Right.
My wife is working
on Europa lander.
NATALIE STARKEY: So
that's going to be soon.
And we will hopefully
go to the Europa clipper
mission, Enceladus.
Unfortunately, we found that
Enceladus had this liquid ocean
as well after they've already
planned this mission to Europa.
But it might actually be a
better place to look for life.
It might-- it doesn't have quite
the same horrible radiation
environment that Europa has.
So I can't choose.
I literally can't choose.
Pluto is also fascinating.
We've flown by it.
We've learned a lot
by just flying by it.
But it's a Kuiper Belt object.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Yeah,
who knew that was
going to be so fascinating?
NATALIE STARKEY:
But there's probably
other really fascinating
objects in the Kuiper Belt
that we need to look at.
So we just haven't
explored it enough.
And it's just too far away.
So yeah, I need to kind of
speed up time, time travel,
and then come back
and get some samples.
But yeah--
SCOTT MAXWELL: It's wonderful
to have so many good choices,
right?
NATALIE STARKEY: That's true.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Dr.
Starkey, thank you.
This has been a
terrific conversation.
Thank you so much.
NATALIE STARKEY: Thank
you for having me.
SCOTT MAXWELL: The book--
absolutely, our pleasure--
the book is "Catching Stardust--
Comets, Asteroids, and the
Birth of the Solar System."
And all the stuff we talked
about and so much more
is in it.
I encourage you to read it.
Please join me in thanking
our guest today, Dr. Natalie
Starkey.
[APPLAUSE]